yeah well you know technology is
something that is very seductive to a
lot of people day they too quickly jump
to the conclusion that you know all we
have all this great technology now so
the answer to all the world's problems
of war and poverty and disease and
everything is just technological just
apply the right you know technology
version 7.0 and you fix problems well
that's not how problems actually get
solved by technology the technology only
works when it's embedded in the actions
of guess again free individuals
operating in free markets are the
incentives to you know find the right
technology to solve the problem at hand
or democratically accountable
governments that have the incentive to
find the right technology to solve the
problem at hand technology is not a
disembodied force that will solve
problems and owns it requires human
beings to solve problems so I'm not I
don't buy into this kind of you know the
sort of Thomas Friedman worldview that
you know we have this great technology
and all you have to do is just sort of
plug into the internet and globalization
will take over and solve all the world's
problems you know I I don't think things
work that way I think they require lots
and lots of supporting human
institutions that respect individual
rights free markets democracy these
things unfortunately build up more
slowly than technological quick fixes
they are only evolved over a couple of
centuries in the West and they're
evolving you know slowly in the rest of
the world
you